Transcription: Johanna Maheva
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Le premier constat d’abord était
qu’il y avait un accès difficile :
préjugés sur l’accès à l’éducation,
on estimait qu’une fille instruite
devenait une personne extravertie
et qui échappe au contrôle parental.
Il fallait changer cette perception.
Personne de côté.
Tant qu’on va laisser 50%
de la population
avec une force et des idées,
comme vous dites,
des idées et de la volonté,
on les mettra de côté pour cheminer,
on ne peut pas avoir parlé
de développement dans le sens global.
Quelle que soit la force
d’un gouvernement,
quelle que soit sa volonté de bien faire,
il faut qu’il y ait toujours
une personne derrière
qui regarde ce qui n’est pas bien fait
et fasse attention et le faire bien.
Tant qu’on va applaudir
que ce qui est positif,
le négatif restera négatif
et va s’empirer,
la situation ne changera jamais.